tenemos aquí dos moléculas de agua y
generalmente cuando están las moléculas
de agua interactuando forman puentes de
hidrógeno debido a la polaridad en las
moléculas de agua ya hemos hablado un
montón al respecto hemos hablado acerca
de todas las propiedades interesantes
que provocan los puentes de hidrógeno
pero hay que tomar en cuenta que la
química es mucho más complicada de lo
que nuestros diagramas y explicaciones
nos dejan ver hay un montón de
interacciones locas sucediendo todo el
tiempo por ejemplo todas las moléculas
de agua están saltando y chocando unas
contra otras en todas las formas
posibles y además no solo están saltando
y chocando las moléculas de agua también
los electrones en los átomos están
moviéndose todo el tiempo y en promedio
los electrones de estos enlaces pasan
más tiempo cerca del oxígeno provocando
que se forme una polarización y que haya
una carga parcial negativa de este lado
y una carga parcial positiva del lado de
los hidrógenos
porque pues los electrones de estos
hidrógenos están siendo abrazados muy
fuertemente por el oxígeno y de hecho
esto es lo que permite que haya puentes
de hidrógeno aunque todo esto está
cambiando todo el tiempo y todo está
saltando por todos lados y bueno puede
ser que bajo las circunstancias
adecuadas
una de estas moléculas de agua pase
súper cerca de otra molécula de agua y
pase de tal forma que estos electrones
de aquí puedan llegar y quedarse con
este hidrógeno pero estos electrones no
se van a quedar con todo el átomo del
hidrógeno porque ahí no se van a quedar
con el núcleo y el electrón un átomo
típico de hidrógeno es simplemente un
protón no obtiene ningún neutrón ok el
isótopo más común del hidrógeno es el
que sólo tiene un protón y no tiene
neutrón y además tiene un electrón
orbitando a su alrededor aunque sabes
que mejor lo voy a dibujar de esta otra
forma
hidrógeno tiene un protón que tiene una
carga positiva en el núcleo y un
electrón orbitando alrededor de ese
protón aunque tal vez más bien
deberíamos decir que está saltando en el
orbital pero bueno por aquí estos
electrones de este enlace están siendo
abrazados muy fuertemente por el átomo
de oxígeno acá y de hecho esto es lo que
provoca que haya una carga parcial
negativa de este lado y una carga
parcial positiva por acá
así es que estos de por sí ya están
siendo atraídos por esta carga parcial
positiva recuerda que esta otra molécula
de agua también tiene una carga parcial
negativa por aquí de hecho esto está
formando un puente de hidrógeno y
entonces puede formar un enlace con el
hidrógeno mientras que estos dos
electrones de este enlace que por cierto
uno de esos dos electrones antes
suponíamos que era parte del hidrógeno
pero esos dos electrones se quedan en el
oxígeno y en esta circunstancia que no
estoy diciendo que suceda todo
tiempo pero cuando esto sucede qué
lo que nos queda tú es lo que nos queda
por aquí esta molécula en lugar de ser
una molécula normal de agua se vería así
que tenemos un oxígeno pero ahora en
lugar de tener dos hidrógenos ahora
tiene otro hidrógeno un tercer hidrógeno
si es que tenemos estos dos enlaces
covalentes con los hidrógenos este par
de electrones libres pero ahora este par
de electrones libres que circule con
azul lo estamos compartiendo con el
protón de hidrógeno no hay que ir
formando este enlace mientras que este
electrón de aquí se quedó con este otro
oxígeno y ahora esta molécula de agua
perdió este protón de hidrógeno pero se
quedó con los dos electrones de este
enlace así es que esta molécula se va a
ver así tenemos el oxígeno ahora este
oxígeno está enlazado únicamente con un
hidrógeno un hidrógeno y está su enlace
con el hidrógeno tiene estos pares de
electrones libres
pares de electrones libres pero además
se quedó con los dos electrones de este
enlace covalente entonces tiene otro par
de electrones libres por aquí así es que
esta molécula ganó un protón sin ganar
ningún electrón y por lo tanto ahora
tiene una carga positiva mientras que
esta otra molécula perdía un protón y
perdió únicamente un protón se quedó con
los dos electrones y así es que ahora
tiene una carga negativa ok y de esta
forma a partir de dos moléculas de agua
neutrales obtuvimos dos iones el ión que
tenemos aquí en la izquierda es h 3
y tiene una carga positiva este donde
aquí se llama hidro neo y veraneo y esta
otra molécula de aquí es o h con una
carga negativa o h - y como es unión que
tiene una carga negativa es un unión y
se llama a la unión hidróxido aunque eso
lo voy a escribir hidróxido así es que
si tenemos muchas moléculas de agua esto
va a suceder automáticamente no estoy
diciendo que ocurre mucho pero bajo las
condiciones adecuadas se va a dar esta
reacción
ok tenemos dos moléculas de agua y una
de ellas se va a quedar únicamente con
el protón del hidrógeno formando estos
dos iones porque las moléculas de agua
se han auto ionizado y este fenómeno se
llama la autorización del agua aunque a
veces también se le puede llamar la auto
disociación del agua pero generalmente
se le llama la autorización del agua
y vamos a escribirlo por aquí
autorización del agua pero yo realmente
quiero que quede muy claro lo que pasó
aquí este átomo de hidrógeno que al
principio era un protón y un electrón el
típico isótopo del hidrógeno que no
tiene un neutrón en el núcleo en este
átomo de hidrógeno este electrón que
estaba por aquí se quedó con el oxígeno
mientras que el protón este protón de
aquí se fue con la otra molécula de agua
y ahora está por aquí dándole una carga
positiva a esa otra molécula y bueno
ahorita tú podrías llegar y preguntarme
oye qué tan frecuentemente me voy a
encontrar un guión y drone yo en el agua
bueno pues la concentración del
hidrógeno en el agua aunque mejor
dibujemos por aquí primero un vaso de
agua lo que vamos a decir que aquí
tenemos un litro de agua
y la concentración de idron yo en un
litro de agua la concentración de h3o y
para denotar concentración pongo aquí
estos paréntesis cuadrados la
concentración del libro neo en un litro
de agua es igual a 1 por 10 a la menos 7
molar y ésta md molar significa moles
por litro ok esto de aquí es igual a 1
por 10 a la menos siete moles por litro
y ahorita tú podrías preguntarme oye
pero que son los moles y entonces te
recomiendo que veas un vídeo acerca de
que es un mol
pero pues un mol es simplemente una
cantidad de moléculas porque es como
decir una docena claro que un mole es
muchísimo más grande una docena es
simplemente 12 de alguna cosa mientras
que los moles son muchísimo más grandes
porque hay un molde es aproximadamente
6.0 2 por 10 a la 23
lo vamos a escribir por aquí un gol es
aproximadamente 6.02 por 10 a la 23 ok
es esta cantidad de algo y generalmente
estamos hablando de moléculas en un
molde alguna sustancia es 6.022 y los
decimales siguen por 10 a la 23
moléculas de esa sustancia estos 10 que
si queremos saber cuántas moléculas
tenemos en total podemos poner por aquí
1 por 10 a la menos 7 tenemos moles por
litro moles por litro pero sabemos que
hay 6 puntos 0 2 por 10 a la 23
moléculas por mol aunque sabes que vamos
a aproximar esto entonces aquí esto es
una aproximación mccray por 6 por 10 a
la 23
moléculas por mol y entonces moles se
cancelan con mole y multiplicamos estos
dos números y nos queda 6 por 10 a la
menos 7 por 10 a la 23 o sea por 10 a la
23 menos 7 que es 16 y nos quedan
moléculas por litro moléculas
por litro aproximadamente entonces
nuestra primera reacción puede ser oye
eso es muchísimo 6 por 10 a la 16 es un
número inmenso entonces vamos a tener
muchísimas moléculas de hidrógeno en
todo nuestro litro de agua pero tenemos
que recordar que hay muchísimas
demasiadas moléculas de agua en un litro
de agua lo que hay de hecho un litro de
agua contiene aproximadamente 56 moles
de moléculas de agua ok
un litro de h2o contiene contiene
aproximadamente 56
moles
d
agua así es que en un litro de agua
tenemos 56 moles de h2o y 1 por 10 a lo
menos siete moles de hibernia porque
esto lo vamos a hacer por aquí por cada
litro de agua tenemos uno por diez a lo
menos siete moles
de h3 o
por cada 56 moles de h2o así es que como
podemos observar la proporción es súper
pequeña crea y vamos a necesitar más
espacio realmente es una proporción muy
pequeña ok es 1 por 10 a la menos 7 con
respecto a 56 y para poder apreciar bien
esta proporción vamos a multiplicar por
10 a las 7 ok eso es igual
esto de aquí se queda como un 1
por aquí tenemos 56 por 10 a las 7 o sea
vamos a poner 7 ceros por aquí así es
que la proporción de idron ya con
respecto a moléculas de agua normales
h2o es 1 a 560 millones aunque tengamos
un número inmenso de moléculas de
hidrógeno en nuestro litro de agua por
cada una de esas moléculas de hidrógeno
vamos a tener otros 560 millones de
moléculas de h2o normales así es que eso
nos puede hacer apreciar lo poco común
que es que se dé esta reacción porque
hoy vamos a ver estas moléculas
muchísimo más de lo que vamos a ver
estas moléculas así es que si
quisiéramos que estas flechas mostraran
hacia dónde se va el equilibrio de esta
reacción deberíamos de poner esta flecha
más o menos así
el equilibrio de esta reacción está
mucho más hacia la izquierda y entonces
ponemos esta flecha de hacia la
izquierda más grande pero esto también
nos puede hacer apreciar un poco mejor
la cantidad de moléculas que tenemos en
un solo litro de agua